abbu Abdullah's family have slept on
this pavement for five days now they
fled bombs and fighting in the Syrian
city of Dara
but like the hundreds of others crowding
the Turkish town of Izmir this is but
one small part of a very long and often
dangerous journey to try to get to
Europe how many of you bought the family
already have their orange lifejackets
for the boat trip over to Greece once
more family members join them they'll
embark on the sea crossing that they
know has killed many before them yes
because I have two wives and kids the
new booming business in Izmir is people
smuggling and it seems everyone's trying
to profit from it so cafes and snack
shops now also sell lifejackets
although the Turkish owners were very
aggressive when we tried to film this
the smugglers count for business at
well-known meeting points this is one of
them the sea crossings are advertised on
Facebook and smugglers told us they
believe they're providing a service for
desperate people who have no option I
give them new life because I live in
Syria so it's America when their view
you get from this land to the land of
dreams or it's absolutely finished when
he stood on the Greek beach but miracles
cost and he outlined a pay structure
with discounts for children and babies I
asked him if he can be about 1200 the
children take the huff of the month I
mean 6 or 700 fellow babies babies under
2 years because we get nothing free yeah
we gained access to the secret of
Turkish smuggling routes through one of
our trusted Syrian refugee contacts
families with toddlers and babies were
among the dozens and dozens who gathered
around midnight in olive groves on the
outskirts of Izmir the cattle truck you
see in the background is what they're
transported in to the coast
I counted at least 70 people crammed
into this one exhausted cold and worried
about what was coming next
the torn tarpaulin left the trucks
squashed passengers open to the elements
the four-hour journey
felt a lot longer somehow by dawn the
drop-off point on the coastline was
packed with tired travelers and sea
survival kits as we waited for the next
orders from the smugglers fresh Stinky's
were brought in still in their cardboard
boxes they can't keep up with demand
here right now each smuggling gang has a
code name and their customers are
divided into groups according to which
smuggler they've booked through the
smugglers code insists no more than 9
children per boat in the smugglers
unofficial handbook more than that is
considered unsafe there's 43 in our
group and everyone is anxious about
actually getting on the Turkish gang
leader intervenes
he's the bare-chested man running
interview we're not boarding as he'd
like the boat is weighed down with
people every one of them anxious the
skipper gets a free passage but soon
after setting off it becomes obvious he
has little if any sea
the refugees reluctantly decide to head
back to the Turkish shore
this stretch of water to Greece is only
seven miles long but time lost gives the
Turkish coast guard added time to
intercept and prevent them crossing into
European waters the smugglers are so
confident the Turkish authorities won't
stop this traffic they organized
multiple crossings in broad daylight
by the time of our second attempt just a
few hours later the passengers are
noticeably more worried Achmed's a heart
surgeon from damascus giving up his
career and taking his wife two daughters
and son on a risky journey into a
doubtful future - one for you in Syria
you know when you cross between cities
that's more scary
on board - is a family with five little
ones both parents are understandably
stressed but as we draw close to the
unmarked Greek border the Turkish Coast
Guard comes into sight they order the
boat to stop and we're told not to film
go away they shout go away the thud was
a live round unnoticed colleague to the
left of screen pointing a rifle directly
at us more shots are fired into the air
Allahu Akbar
the Muslim cry of faith right now
shouted in defiance the passengers hold
their babies up to show the Coast Guard
there are young ones on board instead
the much larger vessel is steered
repeatedly closer to the inflatable
but as they move into Greek territory
the Coast Guard pulls back
and the stress and anger is replaced by
relief and cheering they praise their
God but there's also deep deep gratitude
for those countries who have stepped in
to help message Thank You Autobot Thank
You Fran sir Thank You al Manya Thank
You German thank you thank you my heart
thank you thank you Oh roba with the
European shoreline moments away some of
them just can't wait
Europe represents safety and they've
risked all to get here the captain so
right now celebrations few know of the
battle which lies ahead over where
they're all going to settle
Alex Crawford Sky News on the Greek
island of Lesbos